fast X has a cast full of A-list action
stars but we nearly got an appearance
from John Wick himself here's who Keanu
Reeves would have played one of the most
impressive accomplishments of The Fast
and Furious franchise is how it managed
to get some serious acting talent to
appear on screen the most recent entry
alone has numerous Oscar winners among
the cast including Dame Helen Mirren
Brie Larson Charlize Theron and Rita
Moreno that's on top of casting Rising
talent in Jason Momoa and Daniella
melchior however if things had worked
out differently another major star could
have been on the roster Alan richson who
stars as seen stealer AIMS in fast X
revealed to Entertainment Weekly that
Keanu Reeves was initially courted to
play his part Reeves is no stranger to
action-adventure films being the star of
multiple franchises like the Matrix and
John Wick richson admitted it was tough
to try to fill those shoes I was working
on a movie with Hilary Swank up in
Winnipeg and in the freezing cold and I
got a call that things had shifted in
the plans with Keanu Reeves which is I
think who was originally intended to
play my part tough act to follow Reeves
may not be joining the fast family just
yet but it was a great opportunity for
richson of course it wasn't that easy
even without having to compete with the
star of Point Break richson mentioned
that there were timing issues that could
have necessitated another recasting of
Ames he went on to say basically the
deal was if there's no problems we don't
shut down for covid or weather this
should work and about two weeks later we
got news that we were going to get hit
with the biggest blizzard in Winnipeg's
history the production had to shut down
temporarily and while Richardson's fast
Journey could have ended before it began
the production team was able to move
things around so that he could be in the
movie
everyone becomes family it's like a cult
with cars
however that wasn't the end of richton's
turmoil as he recounted a phone call
from fastx producer Jeff kirschenbaum he
elaborated I was like oh God whatever
you've got to say just say it I can take
it I'm a big boy he goes you're not
going to be working with director Justin
Lin on this I was like okay am I still
in the movie kirstenbaum then clarified
that Justin Lin was the one who stepped
away from the movie but Rich sen would
still be in it after that confusing back
and forth everything was good and
richson is now a proud member of the
fast family meanwhile Keanu Reeves
certainly isn't short on work and he's
had plenty of near-miss appearances in
franchise history for example he could
have been part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in Captain Marvel when he was
offered the part of yan Rog which
ultimately went to Jude Law he turned
that down so that he could film John
Wick chapter 3 Parabellum and he could
have had a very different role in The
Fast and Furious franchise had another
opportunity Trinity worked out earlier
in an interview with The Hollywood
Reporter Fast and Furious presents Hobbs
and Shaw director David Leach revealed
that there were talks early on for
Reeves to play the part of the eteon
director whose nameless and faceless in
the film however as production went on
all parties involved agreed it just
wasn't a good fit so Reeves passed still
there will be opportunities in the
future for Reeves to join the fast
franchise if he wants fast X kicked off
the beginning of the end for the
Mainstay franchise and it's been
confirmed that some spin-offs are in the
works including one that will be
female-led it's safe to say that if
Reeves really wants to be a part of the
fast family any director would jump at
the chance to get him involved
foreign
[Music]